[Music]
mission one start
[Music]
hello folks it's a Monday I'm Eric
that's Richie hey what's going on what's
up Richie we're gonna play a kind of a
classic game I guess in a way I didn't
actually realize that it's coming it
came out on the Nintendo switch but what
are we gonna be playing today
Richie slug - awesome all right let's uh
let's get into the game we paused it if
you didn't hear it earlier we're about
to get in and we're like oh we're about
to start all right timer so ready when
you are
all right let's let's just try this okay
let's give it a go also we're I'm
watching I'm gonna try to watch chat and
play at the same time YouTube and twitch
chat as well as Facebook GameSpot thank
you guys all for tuning in yes thanks
let's do this all right I'm feel and
your are you Marco yes I am Marco there
we go
no I probably should have factored in
that we're playing old-school arcade
mode and that we were only gonna have a
box here so I guess bottom right did
work out you got a crapload of credits
right now yep you can say that in the
main menu if you press L a bunch of
times you can have unlimited credits so
it's gonna be very helpful dude you
never you're setting saved from just now
I don't remember
okay well feel like it looked a little
bit better
oh there are a bunch of settings that
you can change right yeah you saw that
menu in the very beginning there are a
lot of resumes oh yeah that's right
names you remember your first time
playing any of these middle oh yeah
definitely uh back in the day back in
the day they used to have NeoGeo
machines Oh at my local like Pizza Hut
and you know while you're waiting for
your personal panties
that's what I had personal pan pizzas
because that's all you're finished back
when I was waiting for those you know I
would I would hop on and try to live as
long as I could but you know when you're
a kid you really suck at games
it's a lot of pressure to shoutouts to
all the parents who gave up all the
quarters all the quarters yeah because I
I realized after the fact when I grew up
like how much better I got at games I
guess and how long a dollar lasted
versus uh how long a dollar lasted when
I was a kid ya know even going to like
nickel City was like almost a joke or
laughable because there's so many
nickels and quarters just trying to play
games like these I just remember being
like please let's do the five dollars
because we get two extra quarters or
tokens or whatever it was yep for me it
was mostly gone place yeah sluggy
resolution is that built in yes there
are some things you can change and to
make it mildly better but this is pretty
much how I remembered it right Oh give
me that camel there you go oh no camel
with a salt I've got connected laser yep
Laser cam there are some new weapons
into right that weren't in war beliefs
laser is one of them oh there's also the
shotgun which I'm not sure wasn't wanted
okay apparently but yeah that thing
there's ease is also flamethrower mmm
our flame blast yeah yeah these Neo
Geo's were great like I play Samurai
Shodown played KOF King of Fighters yep
that's on my switch also oh nice yeah I
was joking with you that we should have
this Neo Geo stream it he called a metal
slug shame to stick with the theme Oh
like the details are great oh wow even
though it crash on my hand this was a
was a $7 or $8 on the switch I believe
it was $7.99 7-9 yeah oh yeah we should
show you some of those uh yeah like hey
get over there kill me but get over
there what's over these okay we can
share oh the fire yeah you're gonna get
to play nice good call good call I would
have totally thought I would be
invincible to that in a little bit
they'll start like coming down yeah we
can show us some of the settings later
there's stuff you can like kind of like
turn
like filters and women yeah some of it
helped with our latency but some of its
just you know good old Metal Slug yeah
mostly cosmetic but you know you get the
series either in line this guy's got the
there we go stuff you got a voice come
on oh you went for the grenades I did
when he gets closer it does work okay
here we go there now you're safe from
the smoke someone said philanthropy
saying alright died okay philanthropy
bak Ben Janka says one in three run
super well on the switch so it's weird
that twos not so maybe we can check out
some of the some of the settings use
bombs noob says air 403 I had a camel
man I think it was too low to start
using if I jumped I could have next
level yeah yeah chilling he oh she's
chilling she's not so got it yeah he's
just coming along for the trip thank you
oh yo you're my shock thirsty
ah I see that my camel my camel is like
now thirsty oh that's right I'm out of
here I'm there
Ben Janka if you know what settings
might be more optimal to make it less
laggy please tell me and we will do our
best to see if we can change those and
get it running a little bit more
proficient I think I'm like either used
to it or totally fine with yeah I don't
know cuz when I was watching at first I
think that kind of looks a little bit
hard to watch but you know I because
I've played this so much going up I feel
like this is roughly what it felt like
yo I don't know there was always some
sort of wasting my machine gun I got a
stuff I love these enemies because they
turn you into mummies if you get hit
once and you can still play as a
character just you're just wrapped up in
yeah you know just like mummy time your
mommy time slows you down the mummy with
Tom Cruise I'm not looking
I have not seen but well it's not out
yet but yeah I'm not looking forward to
it from what I've seen I'm miss Brendan
Fraser mummy me too
those were good man back in the day yeah
you're like the popcorn films the theme
today is back in the day yes have a good
name
subdued thank you give me those points
save them save them the scrag lers oh
you just take it okay I got the shotgun
I gotta not waste my shotgun boom well I
got the flamethrower whoo that lag
though it's a little there we go we're
back we're back just blowing up creek
you know positive if we make it to part
three it'll be aliens but for now it's
all we're gonna make it don't jinx it
like that oh there we go these guys are
the homies yes wait who got the shotgun
URI Shock Troopers is also a great game
it's true hey man these persons who they
drop the mummy poison on hey drop your
points are you going
whoo-hoo shotgun kills them in one shot
oh you've burned that back thousand I
got out of there oh there's treasure
though see okay here's a question oh
your love me I'm still alive if I can
wait it up for like two minutes are we
supposed to go yeah I fail that
platforming can you come back this way
okay help me help me out there we go
Iraqi boy saying Metal Slug 3 is the
best no slug X it's pretty good too Oh X
concrete isn't really good though yeah
there's really good weight for me I'm
slow I stabbed him
oh now I'm dead to hit something you
would think that as I'm loving you'd be
fine oh you gotta continue cuz you're
scrub scrub here I'm saving that H for
you here we go get it
Thanks I got the perfect oh oh watch out
is that a gas bomb thing oh look at this
guy he's he's not even worrying about oh
he should have already know he's dead
just investigating
want that Darlene no I got one already
okay good
all right maybe I won't play like good
Oh
the boulder Indiana Jones wait I don't
worry I'm waiting for this bat to drop
that thing yeah you shoot him out of
here
oh that's [ __ ] you see my fire got
over there
just barely Oh Oh burn oh hey there weak
to fire right they got right flammable
Oh watch out what look I'm stabbing it
looks like love this game one of my
faves
says uh Caleb chip glad you're tuning in
thanks to everybody tuning in and
watching us do some old-school gaming I
don't know if this is worth it you don't
think the choice hey I'm already a man
it's not worth it I was gonna ask you
like what do you think that like do you
think back then like there were actually
people trying to get like high score
stuff I guess I guess I think and this
game I think they mostly wanted to
finish it yeah it's a quarter munching
game for sure but I mean if you're the
high score two years award no quarter
muncher games were like x-men no
children of the atom and like those kind
of oh [ __ ] I should give you the shotgun
that's right those are quarter muncher
games man
actually I would love to play a bunch of
like side-scrolling games like the old
ones that used to eat your quarters but
like half of them oh I'm like half of
them were like you can't play them
anymore unless you have the og system
pause hello but like captain commando
alien vs. predator the Capcom one like
those are my Jam's Streets of Rage
Genesis do that yeah maybe when they
bring the Genesis back right they're
doing that right yeah there's a mode you
want the robots um I think you need it
you should go for it
I'm good all right fine here we go here
cuz we're about to get to the boss
yeah just shoot and then uh michael
jackson moonwalker who and walker man
save the kids it's gonna sketch now that
I think about it it's a good game get
the monkey rates down get the money
robot
that's right robot oh is that former yes
just oh you lasted I'm lost honey no I'm
here let's go
I know I can't shoot oh he tore off my
guns can you throw grenades
oh you saw one you still have that
cannon Oh God oh just keep jumping oh
I'm out I'm ejected gotta use the
grenades but I'm a mummy watch out he's
gonna eventually shoot a beam out of his
mouth just stick this side I'm so slow
you understand my life you're about to
be hopefully soon out of your mummy
wraps really yeah I was Rockets I'll get
over here quick those electricity is
very misleading because we're we've been
touching in yeah you'll not have been
dying it starts to flash then we get out
of the way mommy grenade why aren't you
human I don't know because I talked bad
about Tom Cruise oh oh oh yes I got the
mummified at like the last minute oh oh
my can shoot faster now yes
you're back oh I've now seen my heavy
machine gun let's go come on and I would
have made this quarter last we died
about me bar no I've only done I think
twice actually
huh that's very misleading I only have
my handgun this isn't helping use your
grenade
here we go rockets yeah BAM those rocket
yep oh yeah
and no problem love metal been playing
at 30 years like actual metal beyond
compare or Metal Slug let's see
why so much slowdown we're not sure
Nathaniel Eggar I mean there's always
been a little bit of slowdown I think
we're just spoiled with the lack of
slowdown in games today yeah why not
Metal Slug on ps4 because it came out on
the switch last week so we're playing on
switch
we're so let's see I can't read any more
chat here yeah 25 cents a day that's
right I'm still on a quarter
remember that don't forget how do I get
a 1-up
I need a one-up yeah no no we're not do
they not give you that's right yeah
that's good username if your shield in
particular your shield too bro oh you
should go have a gun if there's a gun
okay having machine gun let's go oh you
can I need Ben Janko to walk in here and
tell me what we're doing wrong feel like
there's like a filter
oh I don't have on or something there
nada oh I got having machine gun - you
got stuff spraying and praying bro you
gotta save those oh that's right it's
limited oh I'm chucking grenades we're
good okay we're safe
we're good we're good grenades man one
of the nice family don't we I've been
into one you want those grenades yeah oh
that guy tried to get out that was a
mistake
got him with a grenade there we go going
on here oh wow I can't shoot down for
some reason
there you go oh there's a there's a H
well I'm gonna say before you Thanks
yeah go get that mark oh wait that don't
waste that got it oh nice these guys
never they didn't get close enough hey
check this out oh yeah I wanted to save
the guy dude because he's got your needs
nice I don't think you can kill him
boost at ice gets tonight yeah quick
night all these guys don't become like
hittable until they get up yeah I
thought they they got them iframes oh
can we save the pigs
oh let's can we do that work oh yeah you
can
dude are they worth going what out no
the trap we got baited but the pig is
okay right yeah the pigs okay fine we're
gonna cook them for dinner no I got a
thousand points there we go we got I got
baited I should have not got in there
[Laughter]
machine gun there we go take these guy
out I was like okay this guy's drunk on
the job
yeah some poor motor boating skills
there we go
more of them excellent children of the
atom I thought it was Gedge it's just
x-men the arcade eat your quarters one
where you actually had a time limit that
was the worst I thought that was the
full name of that game I had a quarter
when she knew it was like I just
remember like you know how like
sometimes you do you're special in the
eats up time eats up time yeah some
games your health
yeah like double dragon double dragon
that was on every system ever yeah well
we can't chest me and get me killed
what's all right guys go for the chat go
for the chat
the funk said I played MS Metal Slug 2
on every single system including the
original arcade that was the only system
that will lag like this and only certain
parts with lots of action yeah that's
what's happening to us
it only lags pretty bad when there's a
one there's like a lot of intense action
sure if there isn't and we're just
running around it's totally fine Chuck
your name's yeah at these sites because
I don't yeah they're like the answer yes
so we'll just ask that question are they
Nazis or Americans watch out for that
bomb Oh still coming up it is it the
bowling ball let's roll
Oh save the eggs see now get a bacon and
eggs oh I got knives your hats here I'll
save that for you let's see all right
we'll be the other female character who
I don't we go member her name it oh it's
like three letters I forgot already
I thought that when I was was three
letters vo was there was Airy
oh then it's Airy yeah it's like uomo H
heavy machine gun you need that you got
nine bullets okay got a reload reload
reload yeah it's just X my 1919 video
game okay I stand corrected
Bob dunk it yeah matrix didn't know Nia
was in this game
right Oh Oh the airplane oh no oh it's
artillery what are you watching grow
there we go you take it
transcending polygons we're actually
gonna play ffs tomorrow the reason why
we're not playing ff12 today is because
if we were to stream ff12 I think we
were only allowed to stream for like 45
minutes so if we stream tomorrow we'll
get we'll get to play for the full like
however long we want to which is usually
an hour to 90 minutes cool Nintendo is
not paying off - yes you're crazy
I wish they were boy do I wish Oh
missiles yeah cuz I can shoot missiles
rocket there we go I don't know I don't
know if it's just because I'm playing
and I'm used to it Oh quite visually it
is it probably harder to thing yeah when
you're actually playing it uh cleric
beast II says switch becoming slowly an
emulator nothing wrong with that not mad
at that
might as well at least oh come on at
least they're cool games like focus up
listen daddy doesn't have that many
quarters cool seat GameSpot oh you're on
there it a nice game thought playing
Metal Slug 2 now that's not something
you see every day that's true
I love the jet level says Luthor and
more Luthor robot here we go it's
Wolfenstein the new order
Morgan how did these risotto like
canyons work it looks like risotto oh I
hit the ship I gotta fire as many
missiles as possible I'm a member on top
shoot oh I'm so sorry killed I saw the
ball coming it was like it's okay I'll
get back on ah it's not safe okay it's
safe the planes got the planes got a a
healthy orange glow linking good sign
grenade time okay what is okay he's got
the great balls of fire Oh
okay well cigar those can you shoot ooh
yes no yeah you can't their propellers
like a cool dude just live just live
I'll stay down here I'll just live - he
can't aim at us both right I'll watch
out she's got it back oh I was looking
he was only at her nose gas you can
probably get back in no I can't
that's what that thing's gonna blow oh
cool you have a heavy machine gun
rockets instead check them oh oh throws
did again eat this no no there's
definitely slowdowns guys if it's not
the stream it's just a switch right now
but like I said we could have weird
settings on so that's why I was asking
philanthropy who's been genka our
resident files guy in the in the other
room if there's some settings that we
don't have on that we should have on
because when the interaction intensifies
as it is right now we're again you know
those good old arcade slowdowns yeah but
you know that's not stop you know it is
from Barley's no probably really no
problem here we even saved that dude so
maybe they'll come in and tell us
because like I said there are a lot of
settings that you can turn on and off
like there's like a stretch mode that we
turned off right look at that sweet
thanks Luther I love these people thank
you so much yes thanks for watching the
kind words and watching yeah we
appreciate it we do appreciate it you
guys are curious were playing Metal Slug
2 on the Nintendo switch it came out yes
there last week I think the six and I
think
$7.99 yes $7.99
what is that children what is going on
mildly confused by that kid walking up
to that other guy just bowing it don't
approach me Emily firing it everyone
here yeah
oh why is the hostage going down there
yo buddy I'm trying to save you oh I
died doing it oh don't blink Oh teacher
stump I was looking at the dumplings I
think I hit with that grenade all super
good name Oh save that other guy all
right this guy is he throwing peppers
give me those dumpling heavy machinery
hungry we hungry here oh I totally
forgot about that there's a like diet
stuff in a can you can worth it I need
some dietary vitamins
I got bullet a little later do it I
should not have eaten those dumplings
you'll walk it off eventually well I
guess that's how life works you walk it
up but look at how big my bullets are
and how fat man
why are we shooting a double-decker bus
holy my grenades are different too oh
yeah I like being this way key missing
oh no oh my golly blew up like big Big
Trouble in Little China Oh save the
monkeys copy the of a few again yeah I
want to eat oh man where's the dumpling
dude wait all of them I need all of the
dumplings right now do you think this
boat thing has dumplings
let's hope Oh Oh got boo is coming like
real slow oh you didn't eat enough to
fill you up all this doesn't even look
enjoyable says Carlos Andres I I don't
know man playing it's pretty fun I like
I said it's weird
but I don't feel the slow down as much
as I'm playing yeah but there's a lot
going on like when I was watching
someone like when I was watching Ritchie
play by himself earlier it did kind of
look weird so apologies for that
oh yeah there we go baby
couldn't get rid of me I'm hungry you're
gone you're real hungry here we go
thank you oh my got the shotgun it's
probably different to look nice so good
it would be sick if it'd be different
though I would that would be pretty cool
dude I'm so slow man you don't
understand if you don't understand house
there should be a default character like
that would be neat all the time ah okay
I'll take out the Jeep look at you're
sitting down look at what you sit down
it's so good we have to go
take a break chill and spread-eagle no
problem
oh you take the you take this cuz I'm
enjoying my okay okay I love it you'll
break it
how dare you how dare you say to a
wonderful Oh is there another vehicle
you're shooting there yeah there is
there's totally another vehicle there's
another tank there from downtown oh
that's your bomb okay I'm getting bombed
oh that was pretty cool no that's what
happened last time notice yeah me I lost
my there raining from the skies we had
to get out of here I lost all my food I
need more food fill me up
wanna bring the food these guys are
skinny I don't think that food
there so there's our chiller you coming
hello alright there we go thank you
watermelon oh I need some more wait
friends machine watch out oh I did one
of those like Reversi jumps it didn't
work yeah there we go
alright I like my pistol anyways
just don't move they'll make a funny
emote damn it is that when I eat a lot
or in general how long do we get away
whoa dude it feels so weird now that I
can shoot fast and throw fast well it's
right I only have two bombs so you're
gonna have to spam oh no it killed it
okay I'm gonna wait here they do a funny
emote where did they do Mario let's see
do we get baited Iraqi boy did you just
bait us they're not doing any home oh
you drinking water got my canteen yeah
well your sponsee how can white my
character just ready to get on it you
are alert Hollywood no Big Trouble in
Little China - oh it definitely don't do
that don't even remake it it's the first
ones good enough all right look my
vantage point oh they knew no high
ground for you
again and work on one - the slowest
fight ever
oh yeah I'm doing that the one gun at a
time okay I've gotten one down this one
it should be pretty weak up here oh no
that PS though yeah yeah I know okay
heavy machine gun I guess when you die
you drop a heavy machine gun oh there's
another one cool for something I don't
know what seemed like okay watch out
yeah yeah just a locust on shooting it
right like yeah like you kind of there's
one more there we go it's more than oh
wait that was he I thought that was me
no but now it's you dude that thing was
pretty fast
that's pretty alien [ __ ] I'm Marco now
there's gonna be really more because
I've been playing the female characters
only there's another heavy machine gun
for you there yeah he's come faster they
do oh that's how they get you that allow
you to sleep with those slow ones and
then they start shooting these fast ones
oh man I was gonna make my way towards
you ah I jumped into it I'm trying to
grenade the crap out of it how many
Chris you get to start with Oh a lot we
can put it at it that way almost
unlimited yeah see the key was hiding it
from you guys - so you guys don't know
how many credits down there on the box
we have 41 credits now but I think we
started for the late oh yeah
so how many dollars fella got him we got
him that's too tall almost $2 not bad
not bad
we did it okay when you die you get a
having machine gun yes every time you
spawn just spam the bomb first yeah
that's true white chocolate I said I'd
spam good advice the bombs though so
with that boss is a little ski the low
frames is the way it is even on the
original arcades that's right I mean
that's like that's why I'm used to it
like once I started playing was like oh
this is totally like it's pretty much
how it was before like this is not yeah
on the small that when you lated so it
emulates the slowdown - yeah and that's
okay
it's chugging oh do I get that no no
I'll save him for you I got to I saw the
meat go they're gonna eat I can't I'm
sighing so hard to get over there oh I
didn't do it is it only on that level I
bet you it's like level specific no no I
think it's head - oh you think it's
using us all the time
Oh piggies piggies are [ __ ]
everything Oh get stabbed here we go
hit call of duty get call him and owed
commando knife how do we let that happen
I don't know we both like that I I legit
looked over a check oh I took both heavy
machine cuts because that's our [ __ ]
now you lead the way that's all I took
up my bomb see alright alright so I've
used like 3/4 you use one leg 5 yeah
sorry Oh jumping alone he got me with
that Wow
yeah I said that guy that guy had the
commando knife if anything yeah dude
he's flying with his knife at no F's
given
hmm oh nice
Julie are you live here it's you get
like ham and I got shot by it you got
shot by - I didn't see the bullet hit me
traversing underneath that guy thrown
just like you would see more high more
hot themes right now watch out the
high-low mixup watch out for that cat
Oh piggies more piggies more piggies Oh
shucks grenade protip thank you white
chocolate and everyone else you said
throw grenades when you spawn I got at
me well I might I don't have the arm
strength Oh watch out for fighting that
guy oh my god he went over you and got
me that's some Oh fine knives I jump
right in right at you okay it's getting
harder clearly because we've both been
dying a lot more yeah am I like $2 right
now there's like such a gem I love it oh
god no I didn't realize that was the
thing even though it should totally make
sense do we schedule this yeah chat just
gotta listen to check a spam spam bomb
we did it
what are your favorite guys favorite
character use I'm down with Pheo
although I have a special heart for from
Marco and I was just with Marco yeah cuz
it's the og right yeah
Oh laser nice kid his helicopter some
futuristic game Bam's contra baby
constitute laser was the worst gun in
country yeah we try to avoid it and get
the spread Oh God yes Grenadians yes
yeah dude laser was the worst absolute
worst whoa a lot of helicopters not even
shooting there we go we got kill the
leader that red one they won't all die
though
I know he's the one shooting you're
right it's Galaga man it's killed a
front one and then it gives you like a
powerup right yeah ok we're doing good
oh I'm gonna die Oh made it made it boom
right in my face great I was looking up
yeah that's ok so alright I'll shoot all
God I'll shoot the guys down low and you
get the guys up top ok there we go
that's how you do it
yeah dividing the work here we go
come on yeah we did it action pose I
miss your old action pose when you uh
Tony pin rat saying I remember on the
NeoGeo you can only get 10 lies for
character so you deplete the layers one
lives first then continue as player 2
for another 10 laughs that's pretty pro
tip right there
screw you I don't know if that's gonna
kill me you Oh piggy random piggy a
thousand points Grover
Charlotte Club babe oh I'm out of
grenades meteor think wait look at them
there we go we got this it's the
framerate low it gets kind of low
it drops oh it's alright I'll take point
dad that's true I live by that model
every day in my life I wrote it on our
whiteboard here at work to get good that
is Eric's motto you gotta get good at
everything
GG specially games yeah GG exactly what
do you got for me what do you got for me
yes oh okay I got down I got downstairs
okay good
take care of these pesky helicopters
there we go
clear whoa
watch out for that fire didn't follow
you dude
I know that heat seeking rocket this
game is rigged
I like how you put it out there
firecrackers like okay it didn't do it
that time for some reason you saw the
other one I did and then it like floated
up at me some yes get good or go home
says well putt that's correct
you got to get good or go home if you
kill the red huh [ __ ] your burst the
rest will explode with it I don't know
we know that burst thought we did just
now but maybe we didn't see I told you
is like Galaga man you're right I use
that game logic I'm good
nice or say that how come there's no
picking yeah where's the pigs
yeah oh well I can't
oh I got no grenades awesome spam it
come on I'm out of grenades
don't worry did it speed to take that Oh
bombs yeah you were supposed to shoot
the red one and what it caused a chain
reaction to kill the other ones yeah I
know good to know
oh my arms stronger than a train nice
like a commando oh we've used 12 credits
I'll just keep my first we're good oh
yeah we are blocking though or no that's
the whole point you don't know how many
we have scientists all over the place
Tom bows cool so I'm gonna now that's
very nice
Oh Bobby Oh lambie's wait Frank this
we're here hurry up dude get that laser
right dude the laser with they're
turning red bro oh cool I think this is
a you guys said level 276 don't waste it
yeah Oh God oh they weren't dead ouch oh
the knife sucks right oh the neck does
one shy cool you gotta get close though
it's not the ecology to command oh no
nope are we supposed to just go through
here I'll take care of these guys I'll
try nope let's just go get slice
something like they're hocking loogies
when they does all right crank this
thing it's the fire button you got to
get close to it oh I'm so close to it ah
I'm so close I forget I forget it we
don't need it we show them we got it you
gotta you gotta you gotta come correct
all right Oh what I shot them almost
better to just go go open the gate free
oh stop this heat is with my knife get
knifed cool actually I was saying this
stuff cuz they take more than one you
can knife um though that's true okay one
shot but there's too many yeah but
they're not actually like hurting us oh
there's a tank there you gotta crank it
okay near you I'll take care of the door
alright you say the fire button right
it's not yeah cause it feel like it's a
lie alright there we go maybe you can
only crank alright you take the shotgun
I'll take the pain okay you take point
I take point oh yes zombie apocalypse
this is like that anime that trained one
company Reno fortress got it nailed it
nailed it woah
yeah it's pretty laggy not gonna lie
that's really we've got to get right now
I'm just got to get through yeah we just
got it we got a fight our way through it
Oh jokes no problem there's no zombies
zombies going on or anything like that
like watch out for that grenade good
call
oh right Oh save axe I did this dude
thank you
ooh armour-piercing is it actually our
thing it's just another shotgun
let me lob these at this guy I'll [ __ ]
your name oh yeah I see it
they make them that color like bright
blue and orange and I still can't see
him sometimes well cuz you're focused on
other stuff right true if it's bombs
given to me so I can get cannon let's
gas useless I was 100% life what I
really need is I need some effing cannon
ammo who below us normal rocket okay I
got cannon
I think below us look at the water get
out of here big zambie oh shoot I did
not mean to jump out maybe back in
that's a boat plane submarine hard with
the shot something oh I can't I can't
shoot my cannon down there huh oh I can
throw a bomb though whoa what yeah oh
yeah oh you can throw bombs chuck them
alright let him let them all go
what's out oh there we go I'm out I'm
out of thing to and I can't use my kite
that one comes fast okay I'm so dirty it
is
BAM Oh big laser oh no should I keep
thinking that - oh oh no five rockets
I'll sweet
Oh might die though join the club that's
our third credit come on yeah no no I
can let me back in I got Canadian Chuck
yeah me too I did know now I got more Oh
switch a tough boss Oh
shooting four at a time now check those
goodnight I have one left
make it count oh you better not oh so
you got a duck or jump it whichever one
it is Oh checking it oh yeah right right
of this dome thing at this anything oh I
live I lived sweet look at them oh I
can't rock it wasted yeah it's true
we did it
look at me chewing gum when I press down
earlier Iraqi boy in the tank it only
let me through that throw the grenades
that I had so the cannon would have shot
Ford but yeah thanks everyone for tuning
in we're playing Metal Slug 2 on the
Nintendo switch I'm Eric that's Richie
hey watch out hey no time to talk yeah
no time to talk yeah we are on Facebook
twitch YouTube GameSpot if you haven't
followed liked or subscribe to us on all
those fun places please do so as it'll
notify you as to when we go live so that
you don't die the firecrackers like I
just did
cuz this guy's going ham with them yes
but we really appreciate it if you guys
would do that again help you guys out
and help us out we can kind of deflect
where they go but we need to do it
overnight I'm still gonna kill that guy
oh I'll nail him for the cause you're
fat I'll save your hat oh nevermind who
you take that Oh
that's fine we're good we're good we're
good we're good okay they're launching
news we need it getting serious I need
it we need to find a way to throw a
gurney wait that God there we go
precise jumping there will not be a
review for this game to my knowledge to
jazz party
we need a precise hopefully they spawned
me over there get it over I'm a football
player
why isn't that working look at that yeah
it was all part of our plan hold that
don't go yeah forget it it's alright
you'll join me over here man
what's your needs so after much research
MGS our MST's mgs Metal Gear Solid MMS 2
just ran this poorly on arcade
originally wait why would you question
mark that it after you said so after
more research ms2 just ran this poorly
on arcade originally that was from
philanthropy AKA been Janka I heard boy
outside so I think that it just ran jank
is what he's trying to convey to us and
what is up with this swirly has bridge
it's like Indiana Jones
Oh green eyes run there's another thing
this bridge can't handle all this just
Yolo Oh die - well we don't yellow in
this game for sure
we Yolo go you only live once yeah there
we go you only live once and you only
live long enough to have fake and
vulnerability frames that I wish I had
in real life oh this guy doesn't even
knife he just uses his boot it's like
some Chuck Norris [ __ ] that's awesome I
don't need a knife I got my boot I just
dude through your knees hoping that one
hair will go oh we supposed to jump up
there probably oh no firecrackers
this just came out today console hot 92
no oh this guy's ripped that's Rambo
come on oh he's packing trash to come on
come down oh [ __ ] I move wasted three
grenades oh yeah we didn't waste one he
got mom saw me like a little girl oh oh
it's by a whale killer whale getting by
whale Oh dad it's I'm playing this
question mark question mark Ashwin work
I just haven't played in a very long
time what you guys doing they're having
some stew cooking just stabbed oh please
something up there get shot at your feet
yeah okay here's another thing ran a
random-ass thought just watch The
Avengers the other day why is it that
everybody tries to shoot Captain America
in like places he can block his shield
with why wouldn't you shoot his damn
legs Oh someone enlighten me sniper
better snipers over there oh I died come
on come on game there's a lot going on
again do fist why why would that be a
thing right now
whoo-hoo lovely there we go
hey there's gold oh god that one alright
here we go Oh
[Music]
what kind of sniper walks up behind you
and tries to aim down sights Marco says
pilio box yeah Marco Marco rift he's on
a break right now he'll be back Oh what
just happened
that guy had a machete the other guy Oh
take that oh me I'll take it hey machine
gun man that guy's shield is legit Oh
aliens here we are vomiting octopus like
aliens ooh dude I do not remember the OP
maybe I just never got this far as a kid
I don't remember again this weird I
doubt I did hey I'm chopping you get
chopped
wait oh we're too low help us scraggly
looking uh-oh
yep you saw coming I was too late good
night yeah oh no I just jumped into the
board okay luckily hi friends Marco
Polo's I'm down Olo bunch of them who
they squeal - yeah that's when they died
oh he got me with his weird radioactive
gun no that looks like it's shooting out
atoms oh that was a snow your hat I'll
save it here we go oh there's an alien
in the containment so all he's got a
flamethrower we can treat how did we
jump on these yeah you get it I believe
in you yes flames oh oh oh surrounded
great I just got the flame shot - and
there's one on the ground no problem no
problem
Oh give me those come on such a dramatic
death really this tank is the problem
right now
another one there we go
Scott grenade spam gotta listen to chat
gotta listen chat ok just a head of a
hotel ok good this is how are these guys
surviving they don't know these uh these
aliens they're they don't like homeless
Oh Oh weird amen
yeah bearded men dude that was good
another jumping Oh slice of knife slice
and dice um sushi sushi squid okay like
they didn't kill us when they touch this
Oh watch out you thought I was looking
at yeah I know I thought we had some
breathing room right there yes am I
thinking
nine shots one opportunity oh oh you
gave me dumb what was that all about
homeless guy gave me poop it look like a
booty booty emoji oh we need crank it Oh
what is that guy she's faster the blue
bullets are faster apparently who's this
he's like taller oh I didn't crank it
dang it oh I should've took the bullet
for you cuz oh boy it's okay I'm back Oh
Oh see you didn't see that poop I just
picked up another one this guy isn't
worth score points and ten points for
poop nice mr. brain what's up cool kid
seven seven seven thank you tuning in
thanks everyone for tuning in
yeah chillin with old-school Metal Slug
old-school slow down rate yeah if you've
got a switch it's only eight dollars
eight dollars uh Bob Jones says cuz
Catherine America is fast enough to
block the bullets so he can block them
anywhere yeah okay while running while
running bar you can like that answer he
just said okay cool they're going for my
legs oh [ __ ] - both sprays you know I
got bombs that's all right okay
what just making some takoyaki hey are
jumping all over the place is there
everywhere and there's like squealing
like pigs
I miss the pig from earlier mm-hmm
barbecue head yeah except for those
slow-moving bullet things
yeah like the weird you would think
that's something weird would happen with
the aliens like you turn into an alien
zombie like why can't I turn into it oh
oh no it's raining oh I did not I went
for the H I got baited there we go area
clear he might have there you go take
that I got one sit it's cold in here I'm
gonna cold breath our breath yeah oh I
cut it watch out that guy's shot a three
he's got his bread he's got the S he
does dead no he doesn't have anything
they're everywhere
oh I got a cleaver cool Oh get cleaved
who's dropping homeless to you oh we can
we can go get those I think I'm almost
out of this get chopped
oh yeah I tried to get the H again I get
when you get there we go it's raining
aliens hallelujah tech area say I know
that but it's almost unplayable no
matter what platform you play I'm
guessing metal gear - well we're playing
middle yeah sorry
we're fighting middle we'll select two
because it was out on the switch it came
out last week that's why we're playing
him
Oh cut see here oh is that leaders gonna
get taken for the dance floor they're
doing our work for us getting super
shredder
oh no he's not see droid oh oh they're
like now we gotta get out of here
these guys are on the guy that guy hi
Corinne what's up slowly on every stage
is more than enough reason to not play
it unless you're a noob in like slow
down I love slow down oh oh he's got
little spaceships like UFOs
whoo who needs it you need it yeah I'm
out for containing I got the laser
perfect good aliens I got your
technology look at the background
independence a yeah Oh get out get out
get out that's death rate that's a sign
for death rape or some type of probe
it's Independence Day it is
I've watched movies you can't get me
with your [ __ ] Oh God back to a pen
come on I cannot my legit can't throw a
grenade at that thing oh that guy didn't
turn a to watch how it lasers Oh No I'll
rip this pistol whoo yes oh look at you
hi Rico Marco we go Marco Marco fish
idea get out of here
saying hey machine gun does not do
anything to these guys imagine the
pistol sear your gun sucks my gun sucks
worse there okay I'm back to common that
was close
no Dan's got angles now oh oh god we did
it
I don't know this weird I love watching
the background says add pew pew pew
that's right cool kid games all about PP
use uh I don't know if any of you guys
play splatoon over the weekend but they
had another one of those little beta
test II things I think are we bout to be
abducted are we now they're taking part
of the I was like the me horrible [ __ ]
bigger ship so what we need is a virus
that we can put into the mothership that
that excuse all the other kids know we
just go in guns a-blazing man what
they're still alright tech area it says
hence the reason why SNK re-released
metal Metal Slug X was to kind of right
the ship on
oh it says those are the middle
Charities helping us now is in general
is like in trouble maybe cuz it's like
our world versus theirs well no I wish
they gave us some weapons real
reinforcements here oh I'm so oh I live
oh so cold little Smith uh yeah well
Jeff Goldblum
we need help Jeff Goldblum okay yeah so
these little army guys down here or
they're definitely helping us trying to
not doing a great job of it though yeah
I keep trying to keep the be to say that
ah oh how come his grenade can reach
watch look at my grenade that's this is
there's reach this look at that you see
whoa whoa cannon for an arm all he's
dead though that kid could have been a
pro football player
this is insane I need a better gun I
think you can use the shield as
protection by the way okay we'll try
I'll try to do that actually that makes
him more success let me try gonna die we
try using the shield as protection
shield mean fellow military dude that
was a lie this is my widest void I think
all right we're down just going for
credits which means we've used half of
our credits
dude shield guy you didn't shield watch
out oh right through all no problem oof
oh the big one that's on your side
unless it's smart enough to like it look
what I'm doing up here I think this is
working
yeah you got a cheese spot I did oh oh
no they call it they called me out
[Laughter]
normal good
we haven't gotten any guns other than
like when we die I don't know this is uh
oh there you go laser I'm just gonna
streak of the don't ship hold hold the
line oh shoot chat just got disappeared
I'll bring you back chat shad we need oh
we got a day ever okay we got a tank
give me that tank that's right that's
right oh my gosh
watch out Oh big beam using lane you
usually get out of the way
I'll shield you with there we go firstly
take care of the little ones I'm trying
but I'm gonna blow ah little beams watch
out I'm gonna try to use shield guy
shield guy use your two pigs okay he
blocked it the pigs who oh you stop
blocking I sacrifice myself for the pig
dang it I had the laser - way to go the
pigs are okay though yeah oh he'll did
it yeah nice worked they're getting too
close yeah burn a time Oh block it nice
yes do we do it did we do it I feel like
we gotta fight the military guy now oh
no it's like this did come out and you
know joking and I think Independence Day
was oh geez 96 or something how do you
know dates better than I do
so that was heavily inspiring for if we
were doing old arcade terms and they
gave you the like extra quarters before
I start about five bucks yeah five bucks
to beat this game not a bad way to spend
the morning no not at all look at that
now they're on our side
oh yeah drinking that Cantina little
cold at this level or the level of the
game I don't know we're about to find
out finally we did it yeah we saved
Earth it's dated one hour - perfect
timing pretty much uh-oh what was that
register that score oh yeah we're not
online those those might know I forget
it
yeah we did it thank you everyone for
tuning in just a reminder to all of you
guys which news stream every day at 11
o'clock tomorrow we're gonna do final
fantasy 12 remastered on PlayStation 4
we got the lobby coming up on Wednesday
every Wednesday we have the lobby of
course Thursday I believe Peter and Rob
will be back with another episode of
Triforce they're gonna do some master of
the trials is that what nice he's called
I think cuz I know Mike was butchering
it
he's calling master Charles I think is
master of the trials well we call it for
short the trials then I think Friday
Joey and John Luke are gonna be doing a
game called sneak King
someone said that that's the Burger King
that's writing or something like that so
bringing him back crazy stuff like that
but thank you guys for tuning in I'm a
hair accessory Richie thank you so much
Richie for hopping on we did it welcome
Thank You Chet for helping us out Thank
You Chad of course bomb spam is what I
learned from you and get good yeah and
get good that's right get good but other
than that I think you guys so much and
we'll see you guys next time
[Music]
[Music]